red
velvet brown leather boots
ooh white
cuffs a red hat with a white pom pom a
white bushy beard wait am I am I reading
this
right oh it's Santa
Claus my mic
on okay Santa's miked
up where do We Begin ah the story of
Santa Santa Claus also known as Bara
Christmas St Nicholas St Nick Chris
Kringle or simply Santa you probably
know him as a larger than life older man
with a hearty laugh ho ho ho that's the
one he delivers presents on one special
night of the year to children all around
the world but how did this story of a
man breaking and entering our homes to
eat our cookies come about and why does
he wear
red the story of Santa Claus goes back
hundreds of years to a bishop by the
name of St Nicholas born in around 280
ad in what is now known as
turkey Nicholas was known for his
generosity giftgiving and particular
warmth and kindness towards children and
became the subject of many Legends it's
not certain when he became a saint but
what is certain is that he acted like
one known for his good deeds and
generosity which laid the foundation for
our Christmas Tale over the centuries
the legend of St Nicholas spread
throughout Europe each culture added its
own touches in the Netherlands he was
known as Canta Claus in England Father
Christmas in Germany Christ kind these
figures although distinct shared the
comment trate to bring gifts during the
Christmas season others gave him a
reindeer pulled sleigh like young
Rudolph here then in
1823 Clement Clark Moore's famous poem
was the Night Before Christmas really
set these ideas in stone with the Final
Touch coming from Civil War cartoonist
Thomas Nast who added the North Pole
Workshop to Santa's story where you
going Rudolph where you going good
Rudolph over in the UK they had fur
Christmas a character created to be a
personification of Christmas cheer
feasting and merry making in the tough
cold
[Music]
months dating back as far as the 15th
century he was pictured in art and
literature as a large man in green robes
lined with fur who would watch over
festivities as a funloving partying
character
this era began to merge the traditions
of Europe's St Nicholas with the UK's
Father Christmas with the two characters
eventually
combining to create the mythical
character known to the rest of the
English-speaking world as Santa
Claus over time Santa has gradually
gained companions introduced through
poems stories and
pictures
Santa depicting each in new ways adding
to Santa's
story The Elves that help him make his
choice and work in his
Workshop his wife Mrs Claus to keep him
company the rest of the
year and Rudolph arguably the most
iconic of Santa's reindeer with his
famous red
nose Rudolph was a a surprisingly late
addition to Christmas law in 1939
department store copywriter Robert L May
was asked by his bosses to create a Thun
Christmas story that could be given out
to their customers he wrote the story of
Rudolf and his bright red nose
navigating Santa's sleigh for a foggy
night other names included Rolo and
Reginald but Rudolph rode nicely off the
tongue so when did Santa start wearing
red you've probably heard it was in
Coca-Cola's ad campaigns but they didn't
it wasn't
them he started featuring in ads as
early as the 19th century like the US
confection company's sugar plums and the
cover of Humor Magazine puck in 1931
Coca-Cola began placing ads in popular
magazines Koch wanted their campaign to
show a wholesome Santa who was both
realistic and symbolic and commissioned
illustrator hadon Sun Bloom the idea was
to ensure people continued to drink Coke
during the winter months as the drink
was usually associated with warm summer
days and why do we now find Santa at the
mall you know what what's the deal
what's the deal with that why is he at
the mall Santa can I get a PS5 no please
no oh you suck Santa you need to
leave this tradition can be credited to
the entrepreneurial Genius of James
Edgar when in 1890 he got the idea to
dress up as Santa in his Department
Store in
Massachusetts this practice became so
popular that in 1937 Charles W Howard a
passionate Santa impersonator
established the Charles W Howard Santa
School the oldest continuously run
suchar School in the world
we already did a video on that check it
out here so now you know a bit more
about the large man who comes down your
chimney to give you presents eat your
cookies and drink your
milk and from all of us here at great
big story have a merry Christmas and a
happy holidays to one and
all
okay speeding now
here sit sit when you feel
Stu yeah you just rle out yeah youle out
and see what he does there we
[Applause]
go yes yes yes
okay it's a hardworking light as an elf
oh yeah really Hammer oh the
[Music]
hatay so
satisfy yeah oh it's
[Laughter]
beautiful
czy guess see that
again